everyone in London remembers where they
were on that day the reason we are all
here for today
some of you lost loved ones some of you
were trying to get through to loved ones
some of you found a new reason for
living but all of us lost our innocence
on that day our naivety the thought that
something like that can never happen to
me or even to London my background is a
bit startling for others come to terms
with as people had never really thought
that a 14-year old girl
ten days before her 15th birthday and on
her way to work experience could be
caught up in such a tragedy I struggled
a lot afterwards because I was scared of
being weak and admitting I wasn't fine
even at such a young age there feeling
most people here today would have felt
in some way or other I kept remembering
being terrified of stepping on the
wooden slats of the train track in crazy
in case the electricity wasn't turned
off I didn't quite understand what was
happening someone mentioned the word
bomb but that couldn't be true could it
I managed to hold in my tears and I'd
like that adult I was tending to be
until I got the suicide of the platform
a ball game when my mum rang me to check
I was okay
because she'd heard that a bomb had gone
off and I said mum I was there I was on
the tube my mum doesn't swear so all I
remember is her saying was sugar I'm on
my way
now I can't stand up here as many have
done before and say that the London
bombings has had an effect on me that
has changed my life positively because
it was and still is very much a part of
my growing up my childhood my
adolescence but quite often people say
it didn't break us
terrorism won't break us fact is it may
not have broken London but it did break
some of us sometimes I feel that people
are so hell-bent on trying to make a
point about terrorism not breaking us
that they forget about all the people
that got caught up in it not for my sake
but for those who were killed on that
day and their families they're the
people we're here today to remember may
we never forget